from pet monkeys to ice picks and stolen
peaches
sarah paulson's super stylish nurse
ratched has arrived on netflix taking us
on a dark
horror-filled tour of the american
psychiatric care system
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're taking a deep dive into
raptured season one the ending and the
four season arc planned for the series
plus i'll point out some cool details
you might have missed
spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen the show yet
in terms of ratchet's brother edmund by
the end of the final episode he and
mildred have become
enemies edmund's botched attempt at
escape with dolly put him under a
stricter lockdown when he was recaptured
and with an excruciating death awaiting
him in the electric chair
mildred decides to secretly euthanize
him herself
but when charlotte wells now and her
doctor hannover persona breaks him out
he discovers his sister's plan which
turns him against her
with no other way out obviously
mildred's intention was to stop
him suffering an agonizing death in the
electric chair but edmund doesn't see it
that way
even though he himself was to blame for
screwing up their original plan to get
him off the death sentence at the spring
dance
on top of that edmund still seems to
blame mildred for running when he
murdered their abusive foster parents
even though he told her to leave
so when edmund reveals he massacred
seven nurses in chicago
mildred understands he's coming for her
thus setting him up to be her primary
antagonist in season two
and given that dolly shot gwen during
her and edmund's escape
i think it's possible that he could try
and hurt his sister further by targeting
gwendolyn as well
if edmund does end up killing gwen this
could be particularly traumatic for
mildred given how she helped her accept
her sexuality and learn how to love
my feelings for you are the truest thing
in me
i love you gwen's death might be what
sets mildred off down and even darker a
more repressive path again
taking her closer to the cold and
hardened character of nurse raptured we
see in one flew over the cuckoo's nest
which this series is a prequel to
as for edmond's ultimate fate there
could be a clue in the way the tv show
seems to present
some parallels between him and jack
nicholson's character randall in the
movie
for example in the opening scene of the
first episode edmund wears a leather
jacket and green t-shirt
similar to randall's leather jacket that
he wears when we see him arrive at the
hospital and also his green t-shirt
there's also the way that edmund tries
to fake that he's insane to make sure he
doesn't stand trial which is similar to
how nicholson's randall pretended to be
mentally ill in the movie to get out of
doing hard labour in prison
and by the end of season 1 edmund is now
mildred's primary antagonist
just like randall became nurse ratched's
principal adversary in the movie
so given mildred tells edmund that she's
the one who'll be coming after him
i wonder whether he'll end up captured
by mildred and then lobotomized to
neutralize a threat he poses to her
similar to what happened to randall in
cuckoo's nest and
ironically similar to how mildred
originally saved edmund from the
surviving priests eyewitness testimony
and in her eyes mildred might even see
lobotomizing edmund as an act of mercy
of sorts so that he can no longer
continue his murderous ways
what's interesting about how the first
season of raptured ends is the extent to
which mildred subverts our expectations
of her based on how she was initially
depicted in the season's early episodes
in mildred's opening scene in the pilot
we get a sense of her brooding darkness
and inner repression as she watches a
couple engaged in heavy pda then
proceeds to scold a distracted gas
attendant about his filthy fingernails
we then watch her lie her way into a
nurse's position at lucia state hospital
where she encourages a patient's suicide
which she then helps dr hanover cover up
using this as leverage she has him make
her head nurse taking over from nurse
bucket
and there's an interesting detail which
foreshadows the way mildred quickly
insinuates herself into this position of
power
when bucket brings some lilies of the
valley into hanover's office
the lily of the valley is a species of
flower that spreads aggressively in
which is toxic
sometimes lethal already by the second
episode we see how mildred is excited to
observe
dr hanover's demonstration of the
lobotomy procedure on four newly arrived
patients
and with her passive aggressive threats
against anyone who wrongs her it sets us
up to assume she'll be traveling down a
progressively darker path as the season
goes on what are you gonna do about it
what are you deaf no just thinking of
all the things i'm going to do about it
which is why it feels surprising perhaps
when mildred turns compassionate towards
betsy after she's rejected by dr
hannover at the spring dance despite the
evidence of a more human side mildred
clearly has this dark underbelly
and admits to gwen that she holds no
regrets for everything she's done
those were amoral acts and i understand
that completely but you must understand
that i had no choice and if i had to
i would do it all over again speaking to
vanity fair sarah paulson said that she
identifies very deeply with mildred's
loneliness and thinks that what drives
her character is a pursuit of survival
and of finding some sense of home
it's sort of an animal need that blinds
her to the inappropriateness
of some of her actions a character who
we may see return in the second season
is the odious henry
the son of miss osgood who according to
his mother's will finds himself
disinherited and destined to be sent to
a psychiatric institution at the end
of season 1. it's not hard to think that
he'll probably end up at lucia state
hospital where he might try to
manipulate any of the nurses looking
after him
similar to how he had his mother
brutally killed by one of his servants
and if henry discovers it was mildred
who was paid a large bounty from his
mother in return for dr hanover's head
then he might try and blackmail her
though i can't imagine the outcome would
be favourable for him if he gets on her
bad side
by the way there was an intriguing
detail i noticed in the scene when
mildred presents miss osgood with dr
hanover's head
the painting that's positioned perfectly
between the two women is salome with the
decapitated head of john the baptist
like miss osgood who requested dr
hanover's head as revenge for his part
in her son losing his limbs in the bible
salome requested the head of john be
brought to her as vengeance on behalf of
her mother
another way that mildred rationalizes
both her good and bad actions
is through the idea that she's an angel
of mercy this theme
first came up in the pilot episode i
admire nurses more than anything
they really are god's angels yes yes we
are this is further developed in the two
angel of mercy episodes where huck calls
mildred by that name after she helps two
patients escape so they no longer have
to undergo the cruel hydrotherapy
treatments a form of conversion therapy
designed to supposedly eradicate their
lesbianism you're an angel
what you did for those women mildred
ratchet you're an angel of mercy
then there are the flashbacks to
ratched's time as a nurse during the war
when she would frequently euthanize
severely wounded soldiers who asked her
to put them out of their misery
the term angel of mercy also has
multiple layers of meaning
it's sometimes used as a nickname for
nurses in general with florence
nightingale being one of the first
nurses who has dubbed an angel of mercy
and then there's the criminological use
of the term where it refers to serial
killers
frequently caregivers who decide to kill
their patients whether it be for
compassionate or sadistic reasons rather
than treat them
i also notice the artwork on the netflix
page for ratched has rorschach inkblots
positioned behind mildred that give the
impression of angel wings emerging from
behind her ratchet
also perceives herself as an angel of
mercy believing that she's helping some
of her victims find
peace from their suffering you have been
subjected to enough pain you deserve
someone to show you mercy mr salvatore
engineering salvatore's suicide was of
course self-serving for mildred but an
even more shocking example of how she
can quickly switch between compassion
and brutality
is in the fourth episode in the course
of one evening mildred helps
ingrid and lily escape their shockingly
painful hydrotherapy treatments but at
the same time with the help of dr
hanover she locks charles wainwright
into one of the tanks and turns the
temperature up to a level that will boil
him alive
getting rid of charles is not only
expedient as it's yet another death on
the hospital premises that mildred can
hold over hannover but it's also a form
of revenge for the poor way charles
treated her
the series really whipsaws us in the way
we often simultaneously see cruelty and
kindness in mildred
at the same time that she and betsy
conspired to turn dr hanover into the
authorities she kindly asked bucket to
make her
head nurse because she knew he was
suffering from a feeling of lack of
purpose in his life
the reveal of her dreadful childhood
also makes her more sympathetic
mildred is most definitely a complicated
but intriguing character and gwendolyn
expresses how she
and perhaps many viewers may feel about
her when she says
i don't understand how i got so tangled
up in you that's also a nice reference
to the opening title sequence for the
series in which we see characters
chasing and pulling on a tangled red
string that leads to nurse ratchet
something that's also a major theme in
the first season of ratchet is the idea
of image facade and fantasy in
particular our protagonist mildred who
presents herself as the image of a
perfect nurse while also dressed to the
nines
however this is a false image or facade
as mildred never trained as a nurse and
lied her way
into the army falsified her interview
letter with dr hanover
her clothes are stolen and despite her
lesbian fantasy she tries to repress
these feelings by having sex with
charles wainwright and use his role
plays to get through this
there's also the hospital itself which
is decked out like a luxury hotel
despite being financially on the brink
of closing down
numerous other characters also live in
their own fantasy worlds
dolly sees herself as a kind of movie
star and romanticizes her escape with
serial killer edmund this is killer
diller good luck
like funny this fantasy leads to a
tragic end for her though because
similar to bonnie and clyde dolly gets
herself killed when the pair are
discovered by the police
betsy bucket also has a misguided belief
that dr hannover actually cares for her
when in reality he can't stand her
and he himself is living a double life
hiding from his past and his disaster
with ms osgood's son henry
tragically and perhaps ironically dr
hanover ends up killed by his patient
charlotte wells when her psyche breaks
and she takes on one of her fantasy
personas believing had over to be adolf
hitler
that personality is based on jesse owens
the african-american athlete who won
four gold medals at the 1936 berlin
olympic games in nazi germany
in contrast to the others living in a
fantasy the main character who deals
with things in a much more
straightforward way is huck
huck is damaged too but his character's
wounds are more external rather than
internalized like many of the others
and for me i was gutted when he was
killed as he felt like one of the only
truly decent characters in the show
if you're wondering about how long
ratched will run for while showrunner
ryan murphy apparently has
four seasons mapped out each one
featuring a different male adversary for
mildred
for season one this was dr hanover and
it looks like edmund will be her main
antagonist in the second season
sarah paulson has also said that by the
fourth season she expects the show to be
in the events of one flew over the
cuckoo's nest so that could mean we'll
see randall mcmurphy show up to oppose
mildred
i expect if that happens there'll be a
few changes to the story from the film
in a similar way to how bates motel
modified some of the events from psycho
in its final season
so what did you think about the first
season of raptured
and do you have any predictions or
things you'd like to see in the second
season
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this don't forget
to leave a thumbs up
and subscribe for all my upcoming videos
tap left for my next netflix video or
tap write for something else you're sure
to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie guy movie lovers